i've been trying to reach out to you
all day are we on for tonight
jeez what you can't catch me you can't
catch me
i'm lance moore touchdown [ __ ] what
pause
oh shoot keegan's been texting me
sorry dude missed your texts i assumed
we'd meet at the bar
whatever i don't care
sorry dude missed your texts i assumed
we'd meet at the bar
whatever i don't care whatever i don't
care
what is his problem
do you even want to hang out
do you even want to hang out oh that's
considerate
like i said whatever like i said
whatever
this guy jesus you are
priceless ah
you're the one who's priceless
this this [ __ ] right here
oh he wants to okay
okay you want to go right now
huh guess i could do that
um okay okay let's go
he said okay okay let's go all right you
know what
you know what you want to really do this
now keegan
you nut you're not putting me out
yeah let's do it oh yeah [ __ ]
first round's mine oh no oh no there's
gonna be no rounds [ __ ]
it's gonna be a street fight cause
tonight we got a party
buddy like i said first round is mine
a beer and a gimlet for my partner right
what's that uh i i got you a baseball
bat with
nails in it
for my post-apocalyptic jackie robinson
costume how did you know
you